Do we need a teacher to learn a language?
That's what I wanna talk about today.
Uh, you know that I'm a person who
does, who enjoys, uh, self-study.
I'm a self-motivated language learner.
What do I think of the role of a teacher?
Well, I guess the quick answer
is do we need a teacher?
The word "need" is strong,
but if the question were can
we benefit from a teacher?
To me the answer is yes.
And I'm gonna tell you when we
need the teacher or when the
teacher can most benefit us.
Uh, but there are polyglots like the
famous Hungarian polyglot, uh, Lomb
Kato, who essentially learned on her own.
There are a lot of very successful
polyglots who learn through reading,
through listening, and who don't
require the services of a teacher.
Most people who think of learning a
language, think of finding a teacher.
Uh, most people in the world, not the
sort of very active, self-motivated
polyglots, but most people who have
sort of a casual interest in learning
Spanish or Chinese, they think they have
to go to a classroom or find a teacher.
So upfront, I will say
you don't need a teacher.
Like you can learn a
language without a teacher.
However, the teacher is very useful,
and there are two sort of situations:
one is the motivated learner and the
other is the unmotivated learner.
So when I was in my teens, I was
an unmotivated learner of French.
At school, I had a teacher, a professor
at McGill University, who triggered my
interest in French and which subsequently
became an interest in other languages.
And he taught a course
in French civilization.
And the textbook was great and the way he
made it interesting, and he was a little
bit sarcastic, which we all enjoyed, and
he was just a very stimulating teacher.
So for the unmotivated learner,
a teacher can be the trigger.
A teacher can be the
person who gets you going.
So in that situation, if you're not
motivated, you need a teacher unless
you have some other motivation.
Might be, uh, you know, a spouse or a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or something
else, but something has to trigger that
interest and very often it's a teacher.
Teacher can trigger an
interest, a teacher...
you wanna then learn the language to show
the teacher, teacher becomes a source of
feedback, a source of encouragement, uh,
somebody that you want to show that you
are, you know, learning the language.
So that's for the unmotivated learner.
For the motivated learner,
I think a teacher can still
be of tremendous benefit.
However, the role of the teacher
is not to explain the language.
The teacher's not necessarily the
source of the language because
there is an abundance of sources
of language, especially today.
Uh, on the internet, wherever
podcasts, eBooks, audiobooks,
there's language everywhere and
there's an abundance of explanation.
You can Google anything you want.
Subjunctive in French or, you know, cases
in Slavic languages or whatever you want.
So the teacher doesn't have to be the
source of knowledge about the language.
Doesn't have to be an explainer.
In fact, explanations are are rel...
are not that tremendously useful.
If you haven't had enough exposure to the
language, the explanation kind of passes.
You buy a lot of the sort of how the
language works, you're gonna get used
to it and figure it out on your own.
It is sometimes useful
to have that explained.
So here's where I think the teacher
is most useful for the motivated
learner and that is at a later stage.
Because initially the motivated learner
can find content at his or her level,
uh, which could be the many stories at
LingQ, which as you know, I push them
because there's a lot of repetition.
But there's, there's Duolingo, there's,
uh, you know, uh, Pimsler, there's all
kinds of different systems that offer
you, uh, content at your level, which you
can listen to, and you can read, and you
can get, you know, your feet wet in the
language and you don't need a teacher to
explain the language to you at that time.
I think the teacher is least,
if you're motivated, is least
necessary in the early stages.
In the early stages, you actually
have to get in there and start
experiencing the language.
However, as you progress in the language,
and I have had this experience, as
you have some sense of the language,
you've, you've got these words building
up in your mind, vocabulary ,phrases.
You're listening to it, you're
understanding it better and better.
Now you wanna speak.
And when you wanna speak, you
need a teacher or a tutor or
someone to speak with you.
But when you start speaking in the
language, you're not very good.
So anyone that speaks with you
has to be tolerant, has to help
you build up your speaking skills.
You can't just approach, I mean you
can, but I find it less useful to,
to deal with sort of random people
'cause then you repeat the same few
words that you have all the time.
You need a teacher who is gonna help take
you past, you know what you're comfortable
using and push you sort of beyond your
comfort zone, get you to learn more words.
You are gonna hear more
words from that teacher.
Hopefully the teacher doesn't spend
too much time explaining things to
you or telling you that today we're
gonna teach you the colors or, you
know, the parts of the body that,
that the teacher is responsive
to your interests and your needs.
And, and I've had this experience with
teachers where I just, they just lead
me along and I speak more and more.
And of course at LingQ the teacher
sends me a report with all the
words and phrases that I had trouble
using, and I go over those and.
Uh, gradually, gradually, gradually,
my ability to speak improves.
So at that stage, which I would call
sort of, I, I, if we go back to the
European Framework of Reference, where
you got A1 and 2, B1 and 2, C1, and 2.
So A1is beginner.
I think at the beginner level, you really
don't need a teacher if you're motivated.
If you're not motivated, as I
said, that's a different story.
Once you reach the B level, you are
now ready to start engaging with a
guided speaking partner by def...
by definition in my mind, a teacher, you
may pay that person or you might have a
language exchange with that person, or
that person for some reason or other is,
uh, willing to patiently work with you to
help you along in your speaking ability.
And, uh, I call that person a teacher.
Amateur teacher, paid teacher,
freebie teacher, it doesn't matter.
You need the teacher at that point.
And the more you speak at that sort of
intermediate level, the faster you're
gonna improve your speaking ability.
But you still have to continue
with your input activities.
So the conclusion is we don't need a
teacher, but it's great to have a teacher.
I've had some great teachers.
I mentioned the teacher who, you know,
started me off in my interest in French,
and then therefore in other languages.
I've had teachers who guide me, who find
me fascinating content of interest to
me in Ukrainian, in Persian, in Polish.
Uh, so the teacher can have a, a
tremendous role uh, in, in being your
language learning support and inspiration.
Uh, and I think the benefits are greater
the more we progress in the language, at
least through that sort of B1 to B2 stage.
Once you're past B2, once
again, you're on your own.
So there you have it.
My view on whether we need a teacher
and how the teacher can most help us.
Thank you.
Bye.